The harder you try to improve, the less
likely you'll succeed long term. This
counterintuitive truth is backed by
neuroscience. Our brains are designed to
conserve energy, not expend it. Most
self-improvement fails because it fights
against our natural wiring. We try to
force ourselves through willpower, a
limited resource that inevitably
depletes. Meanwhile, your phone updates
automatically overnight without you
thinking about it. Imagine if it
required the same effort you're
demanding of yourself. True progress
comes from aligning with your brain's
natural tendencies rather than fighting
against them. When improvement feels
effortless, it becomes inevitable. This
isn't about shortcuts. It's about
designing smarter pathways. Think of
water. It doesn't struggle to flow
downhill. It simply follows the path of
least resistance. What if your
improvement could work the same way? The
most successful improvers aren't the
most disciplined, they're the most
strategic. Your future self is built by
systems, not by struggle. Design those
systems wisely and watch improvement
happen
effortlessly. Ready to discover the
complete system? Watch the full video